notre famille politique c'est d'abord
une histoire
une histoire qui nous dépasse
[Musique]
notre responsabilité est historique
nous n'avons pas le droit d'abandonner
ce pays qui nous a tant donné
si nous nous battons c'est avant tout
pour nos convictions pour notre pays
pour la grandeur de la france
gagner la présidentielle ce serait
redonner corps à la république
rétablir l'autorité de l'état faire de
la méritocratie une réalité
donner du sens à la valeur travail
reconquérir notre souveraineté
préserver notre planète
notre combat nous le menons pour nos
enfants pour ceux qui naissent
aujourd'hui et qui verront le siècle
prochain en 2022 ensemble pour la france
protégeons libérons et rassemble
[Musique]